MENTALITY CULTURE.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ON KANYE'S
DEVELOPING FRIENDSHIP IN THE
PROGRAM.
WE'LL HAVE ACTION TO ALL OF
THESE DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT.
WE'LL HAVE MORE FROM A
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE WHO I
SAID I WANT TO WIN TO BE THE
NEXT GOVERNOR.
RON DeSANTOS.
I KNOW THIS IS JUST RELEASED.
WE'RE POURING THROUGH THE 49
PAGES.
WE KNOW THE HATRED STRZOK AND
PAGE HAVE FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE SO FAR?
>> SEAN, I THINK THIS IS
INCOMPLETE PRODUCTION.
WE KNOW THEIR TEXTING HABITS,
HOW OFTEN THEY WERE TEXTING IN
OTHER PERIODS, THIS IS THE
PERIOD DECEMBER 2016 DURING THE
TRUMP TRANSITION ALL THE WAY UP
TO THE FIRING OF JAMES COMEY AND
THEN THE APPOINTMENT OF ROBERT
MUELLER AS A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IF THERE'S ONLY 40 SOME PAGES
THERE, THERE'S GAPS.
SOME OF THE STUFF IS INCOMPLETE.
SO I DON'T THINK THIS IS A FULL
PRODUCTION.
I THINK THERE'S MORE QUESTIONS
THAT THIS RAISES AND WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND ASK THEM
WHY THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO RECOVER
THE FULL STRZOK-PAGE TEXTS.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN, I HAD
MULTIPLE SOURCES TELLING ME
TONIGHT THAT THEY SUSPECT THAT
THERE WERE OTHER DEVICES USED AS
WELL.
DID YOU GET THAT?
IS THAT YOUR INTERPRETATION
LOOKING AT THIS?
>> YES.
WE'VE ALSO HAVE REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THEY WERE USING
SOMETHING CALLED THE CLEAN
G-MAIL.
EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS TO THE
ACCOUNTS AND YOU DO MESSAGES IN
THE DRAFT AND RESPOND TO DRAFTS
SO YOU'RE NOT SENDING E-MAILS.
SO YEAH, THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THAT THEY DO.
USING I MESSAGE.
SO WE HAVE TO GET ALL OF THAT
THAT WE CAN GET FOR SURE.
THIS IS NOT IT.
SEAN, YOU'VE DOCUMENTED, THESE
ARE LOVEBIRDS.
THEY HAD ALL THIS HATRED FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY WERE VERY QUICK TO PUT
THEIR OPINIONS ABOUT EVERYTHING
THAT WAS GOING ON.
YET HERE, YOU KNOW, YOU'LL JUST
SEE GAP AFTER GAP.
I'M NOT SATISFIED.
>> Sean: OKAY.
I WANT TO GO TO DISH
I WANT TO GO TO DIS
I WANT TO GO TO THS
I WANT TO GO TO THE
I WANT TO GO TO THE I
I WANT TO GO TO THE ISS
I WANT TO GO TO THE ISSUE
I WANT TO GO TO THE ISSUE H
I WANT TO GO TO THE ISSUE HOW
I WANT TO GO TO THE ISSUE HOW I
I WANT TO GO TO THE ISSUE HOW IS
IT POSSIBLE THAT PETER STRZOK IS
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS?
HE INTERVIEWED FLYNN?
HE ALSO INTERVIEWED HILLARY
CLINTON.
THAT WAS IN JULY OF 2016.
IT WAS EARLY MAY OF 2016 WHERE
IT WAS STRZOK AND COMEY HIMSELF
WRITING AN EXONERATION THAT
ACTUALLY USED THE STANDARD, THE
LEGAL STANDARD THAT MEANS
HILLARY WOULDN'T HAVE BROKEN THE
LAW.
THEY CHANGED THE WORDING TO TAKE
THAT PART OUT AND THE ORIGINAL
DRAFTING ALSO HAD IN THAT
MULTIPLE FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES HAD HACKED INTO HILLARY
CLINTON'S E-MAIL SERVER AND THAT
MEANS TOP SECRET CLASSIFIED
SPECIAL ACCESS PROGRAMMING
INFORMATION WAS IN FACT OBTAINED
BY AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND NONE OF
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN REDACTED,
SIR.
>> SO IF YOU WERE SOMEBODY ON
HILL'S CAMPAIGN TEAM AT THE TIME
AND COULD HAVE SUGGESTED CHANGES
TO BE MADE, YOU WOULD HAVE
SUGGESTED THE CHANGES THAT PETER
STRZOK INSISTED ON TO TRY TO
REDUCE HILLARY'S LEVEL OF
RECKLESSNESS AND HER
CULPABILITY.
WHAT DOES HE DO AFTER COMEY
EXONERATES HILLARY?
A COUPLE WEEKS LATER, HE OPENS
UP A COLLUSION CASE AGAINST THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN BASED OFF OF WHAT
WE NOW KNOW IS A TWO-PAGE
DOCUMENT WITH NO ACTUAL
INTELLIGENCE.
THEN EVENTUALLY THEY
SUPPLEMENTED IT WITH A FAKE
DOSSIER PAID FOR BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
BUT STRZOK WAS THE PRIME DRIVER
NOT ONLY BEHIND EXONERATING
HILLARY BUT PURSUING THIS
COLLUSION FAIRY TALE AND THAT
ULTIMATELY LED TO THE
APPOINTMENT OF MUELLER.
>> Sean: UNBELIEVABLE.
CONGRESSMAN, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
LET UP.
THERE'S APPARENTLY 50,000 OF
THEM.
APPARENTLY 1.2 MILLION PAGES
THAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
THAT CONGRESS NEEDS TO GET.
AND I'M JUST URGING CONGRESS, IF
THEY DON'T HAND THEM OVER SOON,